U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
is due in Beijing but he comes at a time
when relations between China and America
are at their lowest ebb in decades
it's unlikely this meeting will bring
any major breakthrough but it will at
least give both sides a chance to State
their positions and it might prevent the
relationship from deteriorating further
so what's on the table for discussion
here are the five key sticking points
this visit was initially supposed to
happen in February before it was
dramatically blown off course when a
balloon was spotted over the U.S and
eventually shot down the Americans said
it was spying the Chinese said it was a
weather balloon and recently The Wall
Street Journal has also reported that
the Chinese have done a deal with Cuba
to set up a spy base on that island
although both sides describe the report
as inaccurate both are extremely wary of
the spying and surveillance capabilities
of the other
[Music]
an extensive and growing list of
sanctions and trade restrictions exists
between the two countries both say they
want dialogue while taking steps to
actively decouple their economies China
for its part has made it increasingly
difficult for American firms to operate
here while America last year unveiled
major new restrictions that prevent
companies from selling semiconductors or
Advanced chip technology to China its
legislation that will slow China's
progress in areas like artificial
intelligence and China believes America
is trying to actively contain it
[Music]
China has never actively condemned or
condoned Russia's illegal invasion of
Ukraine it's casting itself as a
potential Peacemaker while quietly
supplying Russia with Finance technology
and crucial diplomatic cover earlier
this year America also accused it of
considering selling arms to the Russians
although China denies this America will
want to reiterate its stance that any
move closer to Russia would have serious
consequences
in recent weeks the U.S military has
accused Chinese forces of unsafe and
unnecessarily aggressive Maneuvers in
the South China Sea and the Taiwan
Strait in one instance a Chinese Navy
ship cut sharply across the path of a
U.S destroyer in the Taiwan Strait
narrowly avoiding collision and in the
air there have been instances of Chinese
jets flying dangerously close to U.S
ones it's dangerous and um
you know one of the reasons we want to
keep the lines of communication open in
fact one of the reasons why we want to
make sure we can get that military to
military military channel back open is
so that you know we have a way to to
talk to the to the Chinese about
incidents like this one the military to
military vehicle is just not open to us
it's one of the reasons why secretary
blinken is so eager to get back over to
Beijing Chinese Fighters are now
regularly flying towards the island of
Taiwan too China says it is U.S presence
in the region that is the act of
aggression but the risk of accident and
escalation is a real concern
thank you
the most volatile of sticking points is
over the island of Taiwan Taiwan is a
self-governing democracy but China sees
it as its own and president Xi Jinping
has described reuniting the island with
the mainland as at the core of China's
core interests but Joe Biden the U.S
president has repeatedly said it would
come to the defense of Taiwan if China
were to move to take it by force it is a
deeply complex and intractable issue one
that China sees as part of its domestic
agenda and that the US sees as a major
threat to Global Peace and security they
have and will continue to take
provocative steps we understand that we
believe intense competition requires
intense diplomacy it is responsible The
Way We Believe to manage tensions clear
up misperceptions and miscalculations
even and uh and it is in our interest to
try and figure out a way to work
together and this is what you're seeing
this is what you're going to see from a
secretary blinken's trip when he heads
out on Saturday much of this I cools
down to an increasingly tense standoff
for Global influence and the mistrust
between the two countries runs very deep
indeed these issues will be very hard to
overcome